we can get way way way beyond a currency
and way beyond just kind of a stored
value mechanism as a replacement for
gold
but to do that we first of all need to
understand uh what are decentralized
apps yeah so decentralized apps
sometimes they're called smart contracts
uh but i like them the term
decentralized apps or dapps uh more i
think it captures more correctly what
they are when we call them smart
contracts it tends to actually uh
conflate a contract with a legal term
contract and they're actually quite
different so a decentralized app is not
a contract in the legal sense but more
in the computer science sense so we'll
just use the word dap
and the primary example for this uh is
the ethereum blockchain which kind of
introduced the idea of adapt and so
let's see what how it works
so the idea behind a decentralized app
is essentially a program that runs on
the blockchain yeah so the people
running the program are actually the
miners who write data to the blockchain
and so abstractly the way a
decentralized app works is as follows so
here we have the ethereum blockchain
what happens is uh somebody wants to
create a new decentralized app a new dap
so the creator the owner basically
issues a transaction to the blockchain
that initializes the dap in particular
it creates and writes the adapt program
onto the blockchain okay so
you know a miner in the ethereum network
for example
adds this transaction to a block posts
it to the blockchain and boom uh the dap
is created on the blockchain so the code
is written on the blockchain everybody
knows what this code does this is kind
of open source in that
the application is completely runs in
the public it's initialized to a
particular initial state and let's say
that initially the value associated with
the dap is zero yeah so every address in
ethereum has value associated with it
let's say that initially there is no
value associated with this with the
address corresponding to this dap
okay then somebody comes along and says
i want to send one ether to the address
of this dap why you want to do that
we'll see in just a minute but suppose
the user decides i want to send one
ether to this damp
well so again they issue a transaction a
miner and the trans a miner adds the
transa validated transaction as the
transaction to a block and post it to
the to the ethereum blockchain and then
what happens is basically the code of
the of the dap never changes this is
fixed forever but the state of the dap
now has changed in particular we record
that the value of the dap address is now
worth one ether okay so
what just happened here is that the user
sort of
sent a request to the program the dap
as a result of this request there was
code being executed in the dapp that
code moved the dap to a new state and
added value to the dap address okay so
people often ask well where is this code
running exactly and the answer is the
code was run by the miner who actually
created the block that contains this
transaction okay so the miner ran the
code
wrote the transaction that contains now
the new state of the dap
and
wrote that transaction to the blockchain
okay more more precisely the miner
actually verifies that the state was
computed correctly and in fact not just
that miner verifies it presumably all
the miners in the network verify that
the state is what it's supposed to be so
state one
of the dap is in fact what it is
supposed to be after receiving this
message from the user okay very good so
now the dap transitions to a new state
and again you realize the code in the
dap is the one that governed the
evolution of the of the state of the dap
the next thing that happens let's say
some other user issues another
transaction to the dap address so what
happens now is again the same thing the
code runs
and again what who runs it well the
miners basically verify that the
transaction
follow was constructed correctly
according to the code in the dap and
let's say that what happens now is the
code in the dap decides to send one
ether to some other address okay so this
user has sent a particular
message to the dap and as a result of
that message the code in the dap says
send one ether to an address that is
that the dap code specifies okay so
after that happens basically the again
the code never changes the state of the
dapp evolves to the next step and now
because the dap sent its value somewhere
the value of the dap now drops to zero
okay so that's kind of how these
decentralized apps work okay so there's
a code being created then essentially
the dap runs on the blockchain and when
i say that i mean the miners are the
ones who are actually running the code
and verifying that the state is evolving
correctly according to the code and the
amazing thing is this code is able to
send money back and forth um from it's
able to receive money to its own account
to its own address and it's able to send
money from its address to another
address
so let's look at a kind of a bit of a
contrived
example of adap this is a bit silly but
we'll see real examples in just a minute
this is an easy way to explain the idea
so imagine we have like you know i want
to buy as a user i want to buy rain
insurance on a particular day okay so
basically once the dap is established so
maybe some insurance agency sets up this
dap and now this dap is going to accept
requests okay so the first request is
the user who wants to buy an insurance
an insurance policy what he will do is
he will send the insurance premium to
the dap to the dap address so the
premium saves one ether
and say the user here wants to buy
insurance against rain on june 1st and
he wants the policy to be worth 10
ethers so if there's no rain he doesn't
get paid if it does rain on june 1st he
gets paid 10 ethers okay and the one
eath here is just the insurance premium
how much he's going to pay for this
insurance
the next thing that happens is an
insurer sends a message to the dap
saying yes yes i'm willing to accept
this policy
here's the 10 ethers that i guarantee
this policy with and i'm telling you
that i accepted the policy that the user
suggested
okay then june 1st comes along and now
we have to decide did it rain or did it
not rain well for that we use what's
called an oracle so in this case we'll
use the weather service as an oracle so
the dap basically when it was
established
it basically says i will accept the
weather
messages from the address of the weather
service uh to be authentic to tell to
tell me whether there was rain or not on
a particular day okay so the weather
service basically says sends a message
the message has no value
but the message says on june 1st in fact
there was no rain okay so now the dap
received a message from the oracle the
weather service
it knows it's authentic because the
message is signed using the weather
service secret key
and then the code in the dap said well
fine if
on june 1st there was no rain what i
need to do is i'm going to send
say 0.1 ether to the weather service to
compensate them for their service and
then i'm going to send the
insurance premium
plus i'm going to refund
the policy cost to the insurer yeah so
i'm going to send 10.9 ethers out to the
insurer
if it did rain on june 1st what the dap
would do is it would send the 0.9 ether
to the insurer and then 10 ethers to the
to the user who bought the policy
okay so that's a very simple
example of adapt just to show you why
people might want to send money to the
dap and why the app might need to
distribute those funds as it operates
now i want you to understand that these
dapps basically are capturing what we
would call business logic right very
simple business logic is captured here
and in fact all that programs basically
in one way or another
capture some form of business logic that
says if i receive this amount and these
events happen i'm going to send those
amounts
elsewhere and so on yeah so that's
basically
how dapps work and now let's look at a
couple of examples of what dabs do
so the first example i want to mention
is actually a game but before i do that
let me just it's a actually it's a game
called cryptokitties but before i do
that i want to emphasize one more time
that the code for the dap is completely
public it's written in the clear on the
blockchain in the case of cryptokitties
you can even see the source you can see
the source code is available anyone can
go to this address yeah you can uh
just write down this address if you
wanted to
and uh basically look at the code and
see exactly how the cryptokitties games
operates we'll talk about
cryptocurrencies in just a minute
not only can you see the code for the
for the for the dap you can even see all
the transactions that were issued on
adapt and you can see exactly how much
money the dap has at any given moment
exactly how many transactions were
issued on the dap at any given moment so
everything is in the clear everything is
public and everything is publicly
verifiable that's how these things
operate